imagine the world as a high resolution
place and your eyes looking at it from a
low resolution perspective in such a
world the tools that we have at our
disposal to make sense of it are quite
Limited
Humanity has invested a lot of resources
in the development of science and
technology that can reduce our
valuability and increase our
comprehension of this complex reality
yet we still feel so lost
I have brooded over this idea a lot and
I have come to the following conclusion
in the grand scheme of things what
happens in the world is relatively out
of our control we follow the news we try
to participate in Democratic processes
we try to be active members of society
but still the Monumental change is
required to affect certain aspects of
the world that need fixing render the
effect of our participation quite
minuscule sometimes even meaningless
so what role do we actually play in the
world on a more personal level how do we
properly use our mental and physical
apparatus to alleviate the effect of
complexity on our thinking and
decision-making processes how hard do we
try to understand ourselves in order to
improve the interplay between us and the
world around us
I think not hard enough and it all
starts with a notion of Personality a
personality is an evolved solution to
the problem of an overly complex World
personality shapes our perception and
defines the way one looks at the world
we're social creatures we're not alone
coexistence is at the core of our social
function we are in a sense a dynamic
amalgam of different personalities and
in order to coexist we should first
understand our personalities and then
find a way to bridge personality
differences with one another and the
most relevant tool we can currently use
for this endeavor is the big five but
traits model
um the big five Dimensions
um spell out the acronym motion openness
conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and and neuroticism and
many Whose study traits believe that we
can be adequately and effectively
described by uh our status on those five
dimensions
five is the most widely accepted Theory
of Personality today it has been cited
in thousands of papers and it is
acknowledged by most psychologists out
there the reason is quite
straightforward it offers a quite
accurate description of the individual
by narrowing down his or her Focus to
five important traits and each trait is
subdivided into two more also the
assessment of each trait is not binary I
introvert or extrovert but rather each
personality trait occupies a spectrum
this offers a more holistic
understanding of one's personality and
allows the individual to have a more
nuanced view into his or her inner world
the big five is composed of extraversion
neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness to
experience the power of the big five
simply cannot be ignored the model can
help us conceptualize the world around
us better discover objective truths that
are of pragmatic utility and allow
Humanity to move forward in a less
confused fashion
is probably the most studied I've talked
about and lectured about it for many
years
extroverts need to have stimulation and
particularly positive stimulation they
love other individuals they seek them
out they feel dissipated if they don't
have that social stimulation
um the lockdowns uh generated by covid
are particularly stressful for those who
are extroverted those who are
introverted and perhaps surprisingly to
some of you that would include me
or not are not energized by engagement
with other individuals particularly
every aspect of the big five breaks down
into two categories for extraversion the
two categories are assertiveness and
enthusiasm assertiveness is a
combination of healthy confidence and
the ability to stand up for yourself and
your rights without however
disrespecting the rights of others when
you are assertive you are direct and
honest with people you don't expect
others to read your mind about what you
want if something is bothering you you
speak up if you want or need something
you ask in simple words assertiveness is
a gentle demonstration of confident
characteristics enthusiasm is closely
related to comfort and especially
comfort in one skin enthusiastic people
are more open and they bring more energy
to an interaction they make friends
easily reveal a lot about themselves and
show their feelings extraversion is
essentially the positive emotion
Dimension by being more extroverted you
expose yourself more to the world humans
are explorers and extraversion satisfies
our needs to die dive into unfamiliar
territories this can include more risk
but also more opportunity the upside is
that people high in extraversion tend to
form more relationships and by doing so
they increase their social network and
also the probability of Randomness and
forcing experiences upon them both of
which can prove beneficial in chasing
personal and professional Endeavors the
downside is that more exposure means
more vulnerability and this requires a
lot of resilience and the ability to
confront different people and Views it
also means that the ego can be inflated
and that can affect their mood Behavior
humility and productivity
yeah
neuroticism can be broken down into
withdrawal and volatility both facets of
neuroticism are related to negative
emotion and how the individual deals
with it in the case of withdrawal the
individual will internalize negative
emotion this describes people who are
anxious depressed worry about things get
easily discouraged become overwhelmed by
events and in general keep their
psychological pain inside them in the
case of volatility the individual will
externalize negative emotion this
describes people who are touching easily
offended easily irritated and
demonstrate externally their response to
negative emotion neuroticism is
something very common among humans it is
like a reaction mechanism by the body
that signals a bad situation experienced
by the individual it's like anxiety you
feel anxiety so that you don't have to
feel pain anxiety prepares you for
things that can hurt you it's not
pleasant but it is evolutionary
mechanism and because we haven't really
adapted efficiently to modern society
neuroticism is quite prevalent amongst
us to put it in different words negative
emotion determines how prone you are to
reacting negatively to the obstacles in
your path the more you react the easier
it is to fall into depression because
you suppress your positive emotion
system and you remain stale there is a
clear indication here that the human
mind and body are designed in a way that
demands movement the more static we
become a more negative emotion we
produce positive emotion releases
dopamine which is analgesic meaning that
it alleviates pain so what do you do in
order to reduce neuroticism really high
in trait neuroticism you know so you're
prone to anxiety and a negative emotion
like you can stabilize yourself through
exposure right so don't avoid things
you're afraid of if especially I should
be more specific about that if you're on
a path to somewhere we've delineated the
path and things emerge that you're
afraid of that if you avoided would
compromise your journey forward don't
avoid them break them into pieces learn
how to
and learn how to confront them and that
will strengthen you and it'll it'll
strengthen your character and it'll
lower your levels of neuroticism but
you're you're never in all likelihood
going to go from 98th percentile of
neuroticism to like second percentile
you could but you'd have to do nothing
but that your entire life and even then
it might not work so maybe if you
meditated carefully in a Tibetan Retreat
and you didn't have to worry about
anything else you could shift yourself
two or three standard deviations but the
the the amount of effort is proportional
to the movement right so when you want
to encourage development in people you
have to find the small and performable
step forward that constitutes
Improvement and point them to that
direction this is groundbreaking and it
showcases two things number one how
prone our mind and behavior are to Habit
building and number two how this can
also be applied to associative skill and
affect General behavioral patterns
within the population by choosing
tangible goals that are not extremely
ambitious you indicate to your anxiety
systems that you are more competent than
the thing is dangerous gradually you get
accustomed to the new environment and
assuage the effect of neuroticism in
your life
if you intensely feel others emotions if
you're always incred inquiring about how
others are doing and you actually care
rather than doing it for the sake of
show if you if you're capable of
sympathizing with other people
if you respect authority if you don't
like to seem or be pushy and you don't
like to impose your will on others then
you're an agreeable person and a
disagreeable person or antagonistic
person obviously is the opposite of that
so there don't feel people's emotions
very
profoundly they're not really all that
concerned automatically about how other
people are feeling and they're not that
sympathetic
in the social landscape we need to form
opinions tackle problems Forge alliances
and attempt to coexist the level of
cooperation we can establish is
predicated upon how agreeable or
disagreeable we are as people this
personality trait is called
agreeableness and it is composed of
compassion and politeness compassion
refers to how sensitive we are to others
needs and feelings compassionate people
are more empathetic invest in others
have a soft side and are easier to get
along with politeness refers to how much
we respect authority and reflects how
prone we are to conform to social norms
high agreeableness distinguishes people
who are caring it is like the maternal
aspect of the personality but there is
an upside and a downside to that too
much agreeableness can render one
extremely dependent on others unable to
establish autonomy on their own and also
incapable of forming their own views
this can also be defined as childlike
dependent characteristic extended into
adulthood too much disagreeableness is
associated with low level integration of
various information necessary for both
understanding and sharing the emotional
world of others disagreeableness is
closely related to antagonism and the
propensity of the individual to
demonstrate aggressive behavior whenever
their sense of justice is provoked
agreeabliness is tricky most
relationships are like a trading game
the question is how much should you care
for others and how much for yourself
this definitely depends on the occasion
but a rule of thumb to follow is that in
every human relationship reciprocity
should be the fundamental rule of the
game
so when we look at conscientiousness
what we're really talking about here is
impulse control
that's really the Cornerstone of
conscientiousness so individuals that
are more conscientious they're higher on
that conscientiousness personality trait
tend to be able to control impulses they
tend to plan out activities carefully
they prioritize well they're fairly well
organized
they're good at analysis in the sense
that they take the time to analyze
so they think through situations
carefully and tend to have good
orientation toward detail
the Oxford dictionary defines
conscientiousness as the quality of
wishing to do one's work or do the well
and thoroughly a conscientious person is
a careful and diligent person the
subdivisions of conscientiousness are
industriousness and orderliness
Industrials is someone who is effective
and efficacious they carry out their
plans for Louis well organized schedule
meet deadlines finish what they start
and know what they're doing orderliness
refers to people who like to have their
personal space in order their tidy avoid
clatter follow routines and rituals and
are bothered by disorder conscientious
people value Duty diligence and focus it
is a trait that can predict how
effective one can be with their
Endeavors but the thing with
conscientiousness is that it is very
difficult to measure apart from
self-report tests there is no real good
model that can predict or measure the
level of conscientiousness in a person
and that's probably because concierge
anxiousness emerges from other functions
the actual origin of the word is
controlled by conscience governed by the
known rules of right and wrong so there
is a clear connection between
conscientiousness and morality moral
people tend to follow rules in order to
allow morality to flourish through those
rules but even morality itself is a
debatable topic within Society there is
also a connection between orderliness
and disgust and industriousness and
guilt the more sensitive someone is to
discuss the more he or she will take
care of the Aesthetics and the
cleanliness of their surroundings with
regards to industriousness it could be
that industrious people work a lot
because they feel guilty guilty because
if they don't work they don't offer to
their Community or they don't feel that
they accomplish something meaningful as
you can imagine excess orderliness and
industriousness can lead to certain
pathologies there is always a dark side
to every trade
foreign
reflects the ability to chase new
experiences and engage in Creative
Pursuits people low in openness tend to
prefer their comfort zone and safe
spaces whereas people high in openness
tend to question the boundaries of
conventional knowledge and sick
Innovation openness to experiences
subdivided mainly to openness and
intellect but it can also involve Six
Dimensions including active imagination
aesthetic sensitivity attentiveness to
inner feelings preference for variety
and intellectual curiosity the first
five dimensions are connected to
creativity and introspection people who
score high in these Dimensions tend to
enjoy abstract thinking challenging
problems and are intellectually curious
with regards to intellect we need to
mention that intellect is not measuring
intelligence or IQ when we look at the
personality trait of openness to
experience in general
we know that it does have a positive
correlation even though it's relatively
weak with intelligence
and a lot of that correlation we see
loaded here on this intellect facet as
opposed to the other facets of openness
to experience
so intellect doesn't measure
intelligence
it measures a tendency to be interested
in learning new things and be challenged
it has an association with intelligence
an individual who scores low on
intellect
tends to like to deal with people
interact with people as opposed to ideas
and usually they don't appreciate
philosophy and Theory as much as they do
concrete thinking they tend to view
intellectual activities as a poor use of
time
so the intellect facet really deals with
a intellectual style as opposed to an
intellectual ability as far as
intelligence is concerned according to
Wikipedia openness to experience is
moderately associated with crystallized
intelligence crystallized intelligence
refers to cognitive functions associated
with previously acquired knowledge in
long-term store that is the ability to
access and use learned knowledge and
experience different experiences offer
different ways to view different
problems and that can have a huge impact
on the intellectual development of the
individual
in closing I would like to share with
you my results after doing a personality
test in this great website called
big5test.com as you can see I'm moderate
when it comes to neuroticism quite high
on extraversion and very high on
openness agreeableness and
conscientiousness the test is also quite
detailed when it comes to the
subdivisions of its trade please do the
test and let me know how you scored in
the comment section you can find the
link with the website in the description
below I hope you enjoyed the video I
feel that understanding personality is
critical in our self-development for
many reasons but I think the most
important one is this a person who knows
who they are has nothing to fear because
they know which demons to fight a person
who doesn't know who they are will most
probably fight the wrong demons
foreign
[Music]